all right and we are live the last word
with Lord Candido
and abates returns Friday morning right
by the campfire once again ebox is how
you doing sir
I am doing good burning the candle at
both ends trying to get as much season
of Donny and as I can but enjoying
things so far Game Awards last night and
had to check out what I could we'll talk
about a little shout-out to our
community there in just a minute but
yeah just kind of having a good crazy
week of playing all this new stuff what
about you man shout to gaming Forte in
the building towards the card been
playing a lot of Destiny man a lot of
deaths they had this week also same
thing burning the candle I mean
obviously you've been creating content
and I snuck in one of your streams when
I could so that was always fun you know
saying but uh look man I'm having a lot
of fun we'll get into it we'll get into
the game Awards we have to talk about
that but all for me yeah been really
enjoying what I've been playing so far
and looking forward to talking to date
can't fight talk let's go yeah so in
case you guys have been living under a
rock or just like woke up today from a
coma or something like that season if
dawn is out and it is in the universe we
got a chance to speak with mr. Osiris
we've got a chance to do a couple of
things quite a few surprises cuz Bungie
was a little hush-hush about stuff but
even before we get to that what happened
last night sir what did what what went
on whoa yo shout out I give up way gay
before I say any chat right now I did a
live stream so out to the Rob addict and
um boomstick accel deaf singer we had on
ILP we did a live stream for the game
awards and the free show comes on E and
I'm like okay best community game I'm
looking at I'm looking at the nominees
I'm like okay if there's any shot this
is the war cuz we know damn well it
should have been music but we gonna
leave that alone this is a positive new
release we gonna leave that alone
so I'm sitting there and to be honest
with you II I'm so used to destiny being
snubbed for everything I'm kind of like
go
to the motions and i heerd st dave get
caught it looks MIT they've mark
Noseworthy come up what state mind you
in the pre-show there wasn't a crowding
they should've give him a bigger bigger
audience but that's besides the point
we're gonna accept with grace bro well
deserve man i mean look at the end of
the day this is I don't care what ATI
that you can say cuz I'm a destiny fan
this is the best community I've ever
been a part of a game now like I said
start a podcast with you the list goes
wrong with charity you know and for a
game to be as round as long as it has
I've never seen anything like this I've
never played I've been game in a long
time I'm old yeah like I would give her
a long job I've never seen someone come
back to a game like this over and over
it's out the poem now Paul tasks it was
a cactus with cactus he had a tweet and
it was like you don't like to add a
little your little baby Yoda beams yeah
and it's like my friend coming back to
destiny after quitting at 60 Tiger
that's destiny bro so she keep coming
back yeah so salute man I mean it was a
it was a glorious moment I still in all
that they won gotta give it to you now
like how did you feel when you found the
news destiny that's can win the game I
was like that was that work just trying
to like check here and there doing some
stuff then I finally got him home
throwing my timing when I got home was
great I got home turned on the Game
Awards and ghost issues Tsushima like
started so like they got that trailer to
start but then I like looked back and I
was like wait a minute I'm checking like
tweets and stuff every single what half
of my Twitter feed is destiny to
Stephanie was just like Congrats
Congrats this is awesome you guys are
amazing thank you thank you I was like
what the hell that was very very cool so
seeing them do that and it has been a
journey I mean I've also hats off to
Final Fantasy 14 I've also heard from
multiple people that like the journey
that thing's been through the state of
the game is in right now people love
that thing more than it's in probably
but just about as good of a places its
ever been as well so the support they've
had behind that one but I don't think I
mean you've got people like deej and
you've got Cosmo and Dylan you've got
three Community Managers over
I can't remember his name Scott he's the
one and then on the Bungie Twitter feed
not just a whole community interaction
with that studio and all the content
creators and like the stuff you see
going back and forth ain't just the
support the listening they've tried it's
not an instant fix process it never will
be but overall hats off to everyone from
Luke Smith Mark Noseworthy everybody
we've met like nine hydras thrown the
art stuff out there that we get to see
sometimes like you get to see like the
concepts and like the detailed like 4k
renders and now they do so much for in
their community ends I mean you'll see
points where it's like hey YouTube
videos are getting copyright claims
right now and you'll see DJ's like hey
I'm working with YouTube trying to get
this stuff fixed like the Andrew but
behind their community there's never
gonna be a copyright strike because they
they know their community is half of
their game I mean exactly
yeah and it's it wouldn't be what it is
without it and I was just like this is
amazing that was so so cool so cool man
again the other thing I think that
separates them is I call it like um you
can touch them that you can we go to
these events and you you you you meet
with them and you have conversation with
them the accessibility you know I'm
saying I feel it's something that
separates them you know regardless you
know when the game goes to highs and
lows you know we've heard the you know
the classic we're listening but the
application to it the transparency would
you know this is the only game you know
I don't know of any other games that we
look forward to I mean we do a damn
podcast off of these you know weekly
updates from a studio you know I'm
saying like that that to me really
speaks volumes it's good to see and like
I said look at your chat look at my chat
you know so many friends and people I've
met because of destiny and to see it's
only right if it's not gonna win
soundtrack to me Loki II this is the
better award because you know community
is really what this game is about
there's no community there's no destiny
so mr. Lew yeah that was awesome
and then as I said I got home about mid
game Awards probably actually 2/3
through and then watching it seeing a
couple awards go
there was the fast and furious action
that happened that's will despawn past
that
house it was cool to see him on stage
Vin Diesel apparently will never age
either he'll be 55 look in the same way
but then it came to game of the year and
that's that one got me in a special
place cuz yes there's a lot of stuff up
there you got control people some like
not everybody but I think a lot of
people really enjoyed that game deaths
training divisive but like friends who
really enjoyed it some people hated it
it was all over the place like there was
some heavy hitters that felt like out
there mmm-hmm and then when it came to
the winner I was just like floored you
could like knocked me clean off on my
feet when they were like and second row
and I was like what else like yeah buddy
go I mean as we both talked Star Wars
Jedi fallen orders in this weird limbo
of time like releasing on the day they
got to play before but it's not
nominated so it's like it was an awesome
game and it has that kind of combat feel
to it but to see Sakura a from a
softball game and all I can remember
most earlier in the years like me having
a blast in this game but so many people
throwing a fit over difficulty and it's
still hard there should be other modes
and Star Wars actually learned from that
which is cool Danna cool way to do it
mmm I was like when I played through
that thing it was the moment of like
becoming the samurai and like unlearning
Dark Souls to learn the parry yes was
like when it clicked I was like aw dude
this is freaking awesome and it's like
ching-ching oh and it's just like the
cool stuff that you got to do in that
one and I was just when that don't got
game of the words was like for me I was
like list that I played I was like I
like I had a ball that thing was so much
fun but I was like I never saw it
winning so it had to win to me was the
consensus in a second before I could I
see yeah I'm surprised they did not hear
anything I listened to talk about like
that consensus so to me it was that it
was the consensus it was that what I
call the People's Champ that was the
game I saw you know I'm saying when I
would turn on and all my friends I see
you I see adding all my friends in
streams go I'm stuck here this boss
writing oh man you know those type of
game
was galvanizing and I'm saying and no
disrespect to the other games but it's
just what it what second row had the
community all on it's all it's all to
itself and it was just like amazing to
see when it launched so to see them get
it and again no disrespect to the other
games but I didn't see the consensus
galvanized around the game the way I saw
second row is because des training kind
of divisive right some people love it
masterpiece
seems like ah UPS FEDEX simulator you
know control I had a lot of technical
issues my understanding again device
some people felt the story was great
amazing some people felt the story
always outside you have to find little
tidbits outside of the game to get it we
all know how we feel about Jedi's fallen
order smash was technically an older
game so the competition then came down
to Sakura Resident Evil and I believe
was the Devil May Cry was the dirt one
it was a game of the year so Resident
Evil I knew it might be tough because it
was a remake it was something that
already exists it's like I've heard of
you but it is it's like it's it is not
the first time that games come out the
exact kind of weird so I'm always gonna
go with new IP versus that so in my mind
it was always Sakura but it works for me
I'm not argue and I was just 100% to
Bret never you could have paid me like
alright you get a thousand dollars you
have to bet on something I don't think I
wouldn't look one of any of those
dollars on sec hero but yeah that's
crazy so it was awesome it was a big
smile on my face to go sandals afro man
it was a good one
now so Game Awards happened last night
very cool surprise shout out again to
the Bungie community if you go to
Guardian con shake their hand shake
their hand and shank shank yeah like
community leaders and people in this
community still trying to like mostly
generally be positive and everybody at
their different points of view and
there's trolls everywhere and there's so
many people in the community whether
it's youtubers streamers and things like
that podcasters that are just like all
very very cool it's just listen
community has grown to be something
pretty special can't beat it
see how that was Thursday night but what
happened Tuesday anything launched I
think they had a go button a green
button happens they open a floodgate
now we got season at dawn on Tuesday we
knew it was coming
it was quite there was some surprises
and hidden little gems in this release
that I've noticed more than expected you
guys can see the background if you're
watching this on video if you're
watching it on audio just go check the
thumbnail you'll probably see it but
overall feeling from it so far it's a
$10 season pass if you got the deluxe
it's less than that what do you think
just even for bang for buck how you
feeling about this one compared to
opulence you got season of the terrific
tour you've got black armory where you
place in this one in seasons it's early
let me caveat it's early I'm in the
honeymoon phase I'm in the honeymoon
phase right now um I do like it I do I
was worried that the power chase would
actually have a negative effect on me
because that's prior prior to this this
is all I knew when an expansion or
anything came out so to jump in and to
start playing and you know we'd you know
sundial and obelisks and stuff like that
and more importantly meta change for me
the meta change is really really have an
effect on me right now top tree dawn
blade is something special I'm having so
much fun crazy builds right now claws of
armor Cara double melee in crucible I
know shout-out to teddy was in a chat we
were talking about that in discord and
stuff um in what you call it um you know
in PvE I've been rocking out with um
what you call this some bracelets got
this crazy bill I'm staying in the air
and I'm just it's just grenades
you have raining fire he it's just a
different place now and then um yeah and
then as far as the story you know again
I'll just go through briefly I got to a
certain mission and that was the price
of admission that one mission yeah it's
a part one to a mission I know and work
one which is cool woo see this is what I
need if they're gonna not give raid
right which we expect it which is fair
right you can't deliberate right now we
can't do a dungeon right now expect it
fair resources however if you're not
gonna do that tell great stories right
tell have that narrative cohesion have
that stuff and I felt you know with the
Osiris stuff and then we're doing stuff
for him okay cool but missions like that
part one to saving a legend yeah is what
I need to see because they didn't even
think about it really wasn't no
cinematix I was all in-game right that's
what they gotta do man if they do that
the Destiny community will be good there
will be no issues man so that's where
I'm at with it
early honeymoon phase we got to see how
this thing continues you know say we got
part two next week but for right now
between the meta the bills I'm having a
good time and I was it feels like a lot
to do with the obelisks running around
and stuff like that but I'm gonna give
it to you II
where are you there's I see the smirk I
want to see where you're at though I'm
pretty positive on a 2 I played because
I wanted to before we talked about it
today I played the story piece last
night part 1 so I got a chance to jump
into the corridors of time literally
what's sitting on the background of
those saying through and you stop and
you're just like oh this place looks so
cool we saw the brief snippets in the
trailer of like where's the shattered
where are we and then like you get to
walk through it you get a couple
different places with that kind of
central location with kind of the future
dead trees they're looking all funky but
awesome
mmm and then you go through and as you
say in that final section of that
mission ban enjoy the music the music
the whole time was just sick like you're
going through and you're just watching
this you're watching I'm not gonna spoil
it but it's way late yeah what looks to
be a it's kind of a tough spot and then
like the fight itself yeah like that'll
load as you're saying is really cool but
then you've got a sundial so you got vex
offensive taken not quite two menagerie
but we get let's talk about sundown oh
but yeah it's like sundial it's so I
will say I like that there will be
rotating bosses mmm-hmm so you got three
weeks
you got like a month break and then we
have the fourth one which looks to be
kind of in this corridor section so
maybe we're doing some funky stuff in
there overall I saw somebody tweet out
and was just like thank you put it thank
you for putting another activity in the
game to prove that we do not need
matchmaking in raids because oh no some
of this crap out but I got a chip they
got a relaxed one where people have to
stand on a point all you did you're
screwed I did not have success on that
one like the other two years him to get
like kill the big guys throw the balls
bring down the wrath of the Sun on top
of his head cook him cool do it again
then you've got the one where you go to
the past you've got the minotaurs you
got to dunk that stuff kill the Cabal
boss they're reasonable rotations but
that third one the only time I haven't
seen it that many times with a couple
times I've seen it people are struggle
bus in it right now it's a little rough
in there it's a little rough but yeah I
got a fun experience to I mean I went in
there and I was enjoying it man I really
was enjoying it the mechanics first well
I want to shout out two things one I'm
really digging the artifact I'm really
starting only from the simple fact that
from from a barrier and unstoppable and
overload standpoint because I love that
now I got a dust off these scout rifles
right I got a dust off these pulses you
don't say and right
no figures coming back into my oh yeah
I'm just ready to go I'm good bro I got
a mean roll I was telling you about it a
night watch I got a night watch of
kinetic I put on stop warn that joint
it's got rapid hit and multi kill clip
and I cannot get enough of this cop not
only is it killing in PvP it's killer to
PvE
you know say dead the Lord got to get
the Lord of wolves baby because catalyst
is dropping right now so our having a
ball that I got by Lord of wolves
catalyst I got the Talon catalyst you
know I'm saying so I've been rocking
with that in the cutting knee I'm heavy
because of the 20 paw was the 20% boost
I believe that linear fusions got but I
brought out the crooked finger but doing
a lot of work with that got my mind
spec'ing out and stuff so I've just been
having a ball just again it felt good to
not have to be married all the time to
Izanagi and Omri close my shout out the
rakul we're close is still good y'all
the clothes are still good even a little
bit more but it's still gonna have the
general benefits it's just not gonna be
I can shoot you in the toe and it's
gonna be the same thing you got to be a
little more direct with your aiming and
PC is probably a little easier on that
than console of yours will be but mmhmm
yeah I was like recluse still isn't that
bad yeah maverick clothes is still be
stand out here PvP shot the PvP having a
couple of extra powerful rewards no
pinnacles yet but we got extra we got
extra rolled out I think there's like a
rotator one and then I saw what you call
it one or at least you got ya coroner's
official whatever but it felt I don't
know I felt like it felt like that we
have both said to me I haven't played
PvP is no longer
Wow okay so shout out to the same thing
coming back that I didn't realize
because I stopped playing but uh-oh
other than that nah man I really really
been enjoying it so far
again honeymoon phase but it is really
been cool to try out different is what
are somebody someone loadout you rock it
with what you rocking with first time I
went through the Sun Dial I got a couple
of the new Auto rifle like steel feather
I can't remember the second word
one dnews 7020 kinetic oh yeah I didn't
get the god rule that I've seen her in a
round of like feeding frenzy multi kill
clip but I got an ambitious assassin
multi kill clip and if I get a couple
kills with it then you reload you got
more in the magazine I'll have like 69
bullets in the magazine so I sit there
and just hold the trigger and then I'm
oh and stuff down as soon as I get three
kills won't a kill clip then I can do it
again and it's just like I've got enough
bullets to get going and I know it's
like it's not the optimal cuz it's hard
enough for feeding frenzy would probably
be fine so get Monique Oh clip more
frequently but it still just cool it
actually felt decent I was like going
through killing some nightmares in the
altar of sorrow and I was just like yeah
that's a perfect place for that auto
rifle because I was just sitting there
just mode is just like waiting for him
to come over heel up hill and it's just
a just like out constantly throwing
bullets out there so that one's pretty
cool
I just got Buzzard yesterday but I
haven't tried it yet
[Music]
you cannot shout out some useless
exotics know what can we get to it can
we get to the elephant in the room right
now yo I don't know if you got the Titan
one and I got the warlock one now the
boots look phenomenal I still can't
figure out where to use this thing it's
like dawn blade when you're in door
blade you get kills it's called like
Prometheus something mmm no blade you
get kills and it leaves rifts on the
floor foot where they got killed that
there are like empowering and healing
and now I just got it I'm just like it
doesn't like I don't understand the
practical functionality like where where
can I tell do you have to get to get
those to get to drop in a dawn blade
kill so it's only when you super only in
super yeah it's like weird it's weird
you don't say that I heard about your
Titan one that uh did you did you get
that one yet oh yeah yeah did you use it
it is fine I can't say it's amazing so
yeah so while daybreak is active
defeating combatants or guardians
creates a healing and empowering or if
their location I'm gonna guess you're
helping your team more than anything on
that one is almost like your play
playing a little bit of like airborne
support like if you're up there raining
down fire you're gonna I mean can you
make whole bunch already some places
yeah yeah you make multiple risks and
they last about 15 seconds but I'm just
like why would I choose this over you
don't say like what strat I don't get
what the thought process was was that
exact and to be honest that's again
let's let's talk a little negative now
I'm just disappointed with the armor the
exotic armors I have no problem with the
gunshots a symmetry I like somewhat real
account of climbing to touch that one
the other here it's really though
someone she's kind of cool you know I'm
saying I'm liking the catalyst but the
outside of the hunting one because I
hunt someone I think is when they dodge
the dodge and they leave a little like
waiting explosion which I've seen some
people have some fun with coolguy get
did like a video on that one and that
one actually seems cool cuz especially
like dodgy boys in PvP it's like oh I
got him oh my gosh oh damn boom like I
like that one can be just of that'll be
a royal pain in the butt I forget what
game was it know where you'd kill
somebody and they'd drop a grenade on
their body like an old Call of Duty / OC
OD yeah yeah yes that's the old CEO DJ
yes you did modern warfare baby I
remember that yeah it's like dead and
you're thinking huh bro so many times oh
my god but I was like I mean you gotta
have the Dodge up you use the Dodge you
leave a little explosion but yeah you're
already disoriented of where they are
and then on top of that the fact that
they get an explosion that's like that's
a little bonus grenade and then they've
got throwing my fan I played I saw a
cool guy throw and I played I was
helping him test something real quick
and then I played a match or two with
him he's like hey I keep trying to get
the cross map throwing knife in the
beginning and then on Twitter he just
literally starts and it was on I could
never remember the damn name of the map
he just starts throws it over like the
the box and and just see completely
blind okay
first thing stop it oh yeah completely
blind kill just straight over the ledge
it was really cool a shot single shot
single shot was seeing him shout to the
bernam also shot the local local with
the full phone in the chat he said yo
are blessed is running wild in the
crucible right now y'all I know everyone
I know if you knew yeah or or bled but
it's like one shot it's what it does but
it's like I don't remember because
everybody's trying to get the ritual
weapon yes that's a hey why everybody's
going oh so this is Bungie steering the
meta to say hey what was that wouldn't
revoke her came out do you see a lot
more snipers of course you didn't what
was the previous one Scout got a lot of
range and scout rifles hmm and then now
linear fusion so you've got the linear
fusion it's for the Komodo and it's
gonna be a heavy but the only way like
you're not gonna get heavy that often so
what's your linear Fusion option your
kinetic linear fusion rifle herbalist
and everybody's gonna use it yeah it's
not the best at long range but it will
definitely will ones have you like you
know I got a I got a put y'all on game
right now this last we're a secret don't
tell nobody
oh yeah all right did you get that arm
obelisk weapon cool it's a grenade
launcher in energy called martyrs
retribution
have you used it yeah it's a thermite
grenade it's like carpet fire that's
your name just in that thing for me bro
wait let me ask you this cuz I am you
are the grenade guy you're the one that
did mountaintop legit oh well right
let me am have I is it this a new this
yes I'm looking at it right yeah way
frame grenade yeah it's brand-new
yeah that's brand brand new so I'm
messing around it's funny I'll go short
it so I'm like all right let me cuz it
looked cool I'm gonna get the same yeah
I'm like a shard it whatever whatever
let me tell y'all top tree gone blade
y'all if yeah I got mountaintop oh yeah
I got this this to me is even low-key
better than my on top because you could
just shoot it at their feet and if
there's enemies there that carpet wave
goes forward so you can get multi kills
bro I'm telling y'all right now
these new grenade launches or serious
get that man if you can try to get some
good rolls on it my role is okay but
I've been having a ball with this thing
name
yeah these new weight grenade launchers
man he's breech joints it's fire that
that wave frame I'm all about it bro
make sure that's that's the that's what
I'm talking about the surprises we've
got yes new perks on weapons that were
see it works
we've got year one weapons getting
rehashed backs the Hawthorns come out
there I saw some people with a one-two
punch Hawthorne's and I'm like you got a
new grenade launcher style I can only
imagine if they got goofy like fire I
can see the wave of fire have a little
fun with organ void I don't know what
they wouldn't do with them but that'd be
kinda crazy
oh it's like a Forte says I don't know
look mountaintop is still beast
I'm telling you try this grenade
launcher with that carpet fight you know
what it reminds me of remember that old
arm XD one exotic what is it dragon's
breath how I used to leave like a napalm
just pictured a phone a play prom going
forward from impact spot that it landed
the damage you can do is crazy he said
he haven't got anyone to get it from the
obelisk I believe it was Mars Mars
obelisk get work on that bounty it's
called martyrs let you become this is
the most fun I have had with a good name
launch it is I'm having a blast with it
man I was like it's just a thermite
grenade so it's not real surprising to
me look I'm you're a Titan you about
that life yes I know family yeah Titan
if this is this much fun clearly that I
do like I will say that's an archetype
very cool
just not like a giant surprise to me
because I throw that grenade all the
time in PvE so that wasn't that one's
not new to me it's just hiding from a
source Titan stop oh yeah
how's your three fireballs I was like
how is it by the way thanks oh my god yo
you i'ma tell you right now you gettin
mad with no saint a supernova this is
the joint to get mad at it doesn't
hit kill but all I gotta do is do the
light damage to you with a gun and if
you're that one does it track down
hallways you could get multi kills if
people are weak enough
it is crazy you run claws armored car
with two ities and a strength build to
keep getting melee it is it is
disgusting
I've been I've been hovering in the air
then using my little Twilight garrison
when they shoot at me to dip out the way
like a hunter I'm having so much aerial
fun and controlling a map up top dawn
blade is a problem I'm telling on PvP I
was like and then you've got the hunter
throwing knife I was helping cool guy
test that a little bit it is like kind
of nearly a frozen rope but a frozen
rope enough that it will track again
back to your head from 40 meters mm what
about the ricochet because I've heard
she's right I mean we weren't talking
that one I just was like from 40 meters
straight he just aimed at my head
through it and still tagged me why and
he would even try it like I would watch
it he's like a pitcher throwing a
curveball Bailey like over here and goes
Sheamus is like when I'm watching a
projectile travel and nameís this is
like I'm like yeah so that was actually
really cool to kind of like test with
him and see because yeah 40 meters near
like near that pretty much gonna stick
just for zero straight I mean yeah
there's probably gonna be an arc later
on and I don't think he'll one hit
outside of 40 cuz I think that was the
key outside of 40 I don't know if it'll
one mm-hm
or if it would track his heart but yeah
dude that was crazy
have you done any burning mole
I really haven't that much I've been
focused on other stuff I haven't jumped
in there yet so I know I know I'm
letting down the solar game here I'll
get there I got killed by a hammer in
PvP what you never had before the one
that he could pick and pick up again
yeah that one the throwing so I was like
like you thank you you can't single shot
that one unless you get like the perch
stacked up pretty high but okay you got
to get like melee or male or like solar
solar kill and then if you get it
stacked yeah it's powerful but
somebody's already put some working to
get there just a single shot but yeah
yeah so we got some surprises so the
subclass have been cool I've seen people
loving those testing those things out
perks what have you seen on perks man we
got some new ones yeah I know the one
that I've seen that kind of is really
cool is osmosis it's the one on yes
on Buzzard I don't I think it's in other
places too but that's at least where I
saw it first
and you've got the ability to have
basically all three art types of damage
yeah so you throw a grenade and whatever
your subclass type is and that's what
that that gun is gonna be until you put
it away yeah so if you're like handy to
break a shield but I missed with my dumb
grenade this time well my sidearms here
and I'm ready and I can take care of
that like match game now much more
manageable I'm out I know it's a sidearm
but like especially if you're running a
team and you're like all I got to depend
on a grenade for this that or the other
then now finally you've got a I got a
match game it's covered I was like
that's cool yeah I haven't gotten too
many of the new perks besides that one
you mentioned you know I'm saying but um
it's just cool to see them it's just
cool I'm seeing people you know talk
about bro you have a kinetic weapon and
it has that functionality so now it's
almost like you have an extra burn you
know on all three slots now and that's
dope man and it were my shout to season
tell you who we had on last word last
week it reminds me he reminds him of the
old was it warlock had a fusion core
Susanoo that kind of had that thing
based on your subclass that you use and
we ran and um yeah man it's a writ look
it's really cool that they're adding
these type of perks and meta changes
again when we know this is the ten
dollar expansion we know this is
quote-unquote the light season so to me
going heavy this direction is really
welcome I still want felt vendor
refreshes will still go away from that
or but this is the step in the right
direction
ya know I mean it's like I'm on the
steel feather I think one of the second
ones I got it's this elemental capacitor
and depending on the subclass you're
running if you run solar it's reload
speed arc its handling and void of
stability and
like that's just a cool way to kind of
mix it up and depending on how you're
playing the guns gonna feel different
just the fact that they're making new
perks that I was like we've got we've
been waiting on just that just to be
like hey there's new roles on these
things
thank you so guys shout out to the right
desk conversion for upgrade modules have
you been using those yeah if you wrote a
test version if you go to Tess she has a
new item in her own inventory if you
would not know I know it yeah guys like
me who run through upgrade modules like
there's no tomorrow
they've got something for you you should
use any yet are you nine sixty oh yes I
am nice sixty down now I'm not sure I
just got there I just got until you're
there I know but I couldn't help myself
cuz I had all its brightness I'm like
well what's this so I picked that up a
couple of couple of emotes i had that
dorm blade one got to finish it yeah
just saw me yeah I could just like
expend some silver right now that's for
yeah no doubt too slow on you ready for
that's the experience for the Xbox mini
ATX top yes I am baby yes I looks like a
little PC are you doing that sixty
frames but I'm buying it Forte I'm doing
it looks I got the brightness I'm
throwing money at the screen I don't
want to fall now low key alright let's
get it to ethics just real quick eat do
you think does is that silver that that
little material it's cold what does it
call y'all yeah I know what I'm looking
for a chance to get an upgrade module to
drop yes or I'm looking at it right now
it's going on I'm trading I concentrated
matter gem consumable yeah I'm looking
for it to where the hell is so it's the
same way Isis have channels drop an
upgrade module when defeated effect
lasts until an upgrade modules found
only one concentrated matter matter Jim
and can be active at one time mmm-hmm I
don't run out of those things so you
rich
no I'm hoarder there's a big difference
yes I don't spin the stuff that's the
big difference I mean no I don't like
their there flirting like the upgrade
but honestly like infusion is one of
those things that's still even low know
he had a videos like infusion should
even be in here it's like that's there's
so many pieces to the armor thing and
armor 2.0 is its own mess of stuff if we
ever give into again but mm-hmm I don't
know there's like if you have planetary
material I would I would be surprised
you would want to spend it on that
actually bright dust is so hard to come
by
yeah it is I would rather go far if I
was like broke I would much rather go
farm like a couple weekly bounties and
go buy one of those upgrade modules at
the gunsmith as opposed to like spending
my bright dust this is just like they're
trying to give all the places for people
like you who've hoarded too much who are
like hey I need to upgrade like crazy
cuz I gotta get some more of that crack
like y'all are nuts like it's not that
was are you not worth that and then
things are gonna be starting trigger up
higher anyway so you know what my
problem is the problem is shot to hell
boogie because she says I you I use
upgrade modules all the time I'm 920 and
I like some of the rolls
that's why sometimes I'm getting these
rolled and I'm like oh oh this goes
perfect with what I'm trying to do and I
don't want to get rid of this but I want
to kind of use that right now play with
this bills what are you playing in that
you need to upgrade unless you're gonna
go run a legend nightfall a reign a
dungeon most of the content is not high
enough you need to upgrade just cuz
you're know what goes up and like the
Sun Dial it's like eight twenty or eight
sixty and all the patrols there's so
many places in the game you don't need
to upgrade just easily [ __ ] wait no yeah
no because I wanna have fun like put all
my clothes put on bummy clothes just so
my light goes up I want to play with
what I want to play with now I don't
want to wait that was lastly at your
level I know she's nine twenty that's a
little farther but at your level those
ten power levels there's no reason you
should have infused zero because that
makes no effect on your gameplay I want
to pick my outfit damn it
play with your outfit but bid I gotta
take off when I got a pick off and put
on this other thing because you know go
up at night and yeah okay your your
drops aren't affected by what you're
wearing nothing in the game unless
you're going into Hard difficulty stuff
is gonna matter on what you're wearing
and especially from 950 to 960 which I
know you're at you had zero reason to
infuse anything you've got this season
so far none listen have you know the
answer anything you're damn right Camp
Forte I'm impulse-buy and you're damn
right I'm imposed by therefore god like
you're running out of stuff for no
reason place header Bungie got something
for me I'm and I like that I'm doing a
shout out to the concentrated what does
it matter Jim consumable that is the
consumable for me this is what I want I
want to stay rockin what I want to rock
how I want a racket just upgrade it all
day his hoarder kid he can't stand it up
doing this I love it
ok I'm a horror 100% I will admit right
yes I'm a hoarder I have a pro Nona
rolls for like 3 years oh yeah well you
never know what's gonna be in the meadow
look at linear
look at linear fusions coming back next
season's gonna be like the site our
medic crucible of roles I've got sitting
out there no I am a hoarder a hundred
percent my vault is busted in and it's
broken I get mad
but unless you are running nine eighty
stuff right now you had zero need to
infuse anything but it doesn't matter
doesn't matter so when you run out of
stuff I have absolutely zero empathy for
you sir zero
think it through hold on pause and be
like hey do I need to infuse this right
now keep the other thing that you're
about to infuse on your character even
in your damn vault for the time being
you'll still get the drops you need of
loving the rolls man loving to be up
having so much fun that's too big I
enjoy all these roles but every single
one of those about 9:57 I'm like they're
all nothing really matters if it's nine
fifty seven or nine sixty that was
hurt my feelings you don't never get
attached when you get an armored piece
and it's like yo it got 20 in a leg off
the rib yeah don't get excited
like I get excited when I see something
like right now because I'm on a top tree
um dawn blade I'm actually getting
excited on strength now I would pay
strength no mine right then I'm getting
like 15 or strength off the RIP then
like now with the warlocks each subclass
has their own ability that's tied to
their class ability
so for warlocks recovery ties to the
rift yeah right so now it's like you got
that going on then you got now common
mines where it's like ammo now it's
common heavy special whatever bro it's
like I want to play with these bills and
I'm having fun so when I get these cool
it's like shout to slow-mo see as a
division player he understands like when
you get something that synergizes
perfectly with your play style you don't
want to start rocking nothing else so
I'm like I want to keep doing any of
this okay that's literal I'd never once
I've said don't use the stuff you want
to use but you went into the season 950
hmm anything you're getting is at least
950 so for the time being at least wait
until you get something 960 don't infuse
to 950 two-four-six-eight and waste yeah
yeah I got that I'm like every every 5
every 5 that's me that's my girlfriend
you got you got wait till you get to 960
lock that thing be like hey when I get
that 960 armor you're gonna be my baby
I'm gonna save you but you could still
use that thing up to 950 to get your
other drop stacked up when you get that
960 throw it in there that makes perfect
sense you use the stuff you want to use
but the whole point is you can still use
it because nothing in this game really
requires that high of a level disparity
and it damn sure doesn't require two on
one piece of armor the Predators don't
even change your number at all I'm done
I'm out that's it a week I was like I
said I have a problem you just need to a
minute - so I bet I firmly man shout
this Lobo hashtag i'ma build life god
I'm a minutia guy and all of this place
- I said to build your right I'm being
absolutely ridiculous
but I don't care I'm having funny they
got em I do a consumable for me so let
me have my de let me spend my but let me
be broke they have it enjoy but about a
year from now and you're like I have no
more bright dust ability how's those
damn upgrade module treating you fair
enough fair enough anyway yes there is a
consumable out there for those who do
not want to be patient that's fine don't
shave us but just like little tweaks
that they did kind of everywhere
repeatable gunsmith bounties those are
there set a little more options on those
not came out in a day which is really
cool the mods are good and then the
charge of light I haven't been able to
experiment with it that much but in
theory it's kind of cool have you got a
chance to like dig into it look at it
see some of the mods that they're
capable of yeah I looked at a lot of the
function a lot of it sounds cool
cost-wise some things are a little some
things like four or five and I'm just
like alright and then you know for me
it's one of those things where like I
like to use um finishers a lot one of my
builds is finishers to get special ammo
and I saw one of them that's like
another one it takes like one tenth off
to get you into the charge of light
status so I haven't really activated yet
to be honest I'm still fooling around
and shout out to Bungie for this though
because you know when you you get the
day one season pass and then you get the
new armor that has the season of dawn
perk what I like is when I'm playing
crucible you're playing vanguard gambit
or what have you now those basic armors
are also dropping with that slot yeah so
you have more options in that because
Loki the the roles that are dropping in
the the battle pass yeah reset usually
isn't that good if you go yeah cuz I
went through and I cleared out like my
armor for my characters like last knee
of their season just to clean everything
up and then on my hunter like the first
one you give the package the rolls will
trash the free ones were not that great
I feel like ii like the set of season
pass armor that you got the second set
was actually reasonable rolls they were
like mid 50s
but the first like set was garbage so
yeah garbage is a trash so yeah I mean I
just haven't got a chance to really mess
with it too tough I like what it's
trying to do you know and it seems like
you can make some powerful builds with
this whole charged with light thing I
just got to see it in place have you
messed with it at all so I messed with
okay
small tangent by the way coming up just
get it so I worked on upgrading the Mars
and the tangled Shore obelisks yeah I
got one of the mods and it is a solar
affinity mod I don't have a solar piece
of armor from the new season yet ouch so
I literally bought them out and I can't
use it that's a problem and I'm getting
a little annoyed about that no let's go
go for it like really the affinity stuff
is just starting to get in the way of a
lot of things that was just a prime
example of like hey I got a new mod I'm
like where is this damn and somebody's
like this is it like solar void and I go
back and I'm looking like I can't hit my
head against the table on a podcast so
just imagine is that boom but that's
it's I've seen many people say it over
and over and like not me we're talking
like larger content creators than me
with much bigger audiences the like pull
from and it's just like you have tried
to get and then exotics is worse but you
have try and get the role or try and get
the exotics is like the worst example
because you like first don't try and get
the exotic those are random enough in
the first place you get one chance at
Sur it's a random role so that's 1 X 2 X
is gonna be get it get a stat roll that
at least leans the way you want it to
where it's not mobility and strength
only maybe you actually get some
intellect in there maybe a little bit of
resilience and recovery just so you can
survive then the orangey on top of that
is like 2 X 2 2.5 X is a good stat roll
not a trash roll zero like 2 to 3 X of
like multiplicative rng and then you're
just gonna add one more factor on top of
that arc solar or void and I'm just like
there's two mini and I know we probably
talked about it last week this is gonna
be my like destined Liguria streak it
has been 1,500 until 2.0 has been fixed
or something but get it there's just two
men like the new general mods they're
great like special amo fighters like
sweet just throw it on there I don't
even have to think about what I'm using
that's cool mm-hmm just why can't they
all be that way hmm so the frustration
now is again of elemental affinity and
then Armour 2.0 price of as you're
saying to the price of these mods to use
the price of the finisher being 7th like
the heavy mo finishers still too much
I'm never gonna spend 7 on something to
drop half of my super to not be able to
do anything else like that's way too
many too many cost all at the same time
like let me ask you a question have you
master worked any armor have you used
any prisms and there was any that I'm
not using shard
all right hold on hold on mr. hoarder
okay let me ask you this what what's the
highest armor level you charged on 11
live guys you go oh you don't go up to 8
so 8 is doable that was honestly an
accident here we go here's so annoying
oh my rolls have been going no like I'll
get ok so here's an iron will Greaves
then I got like like 6 mobility 18 auras
Ansel's at coolest survivability 6
recovery 6 discipline like to intellect
and like 17 strength I'm like can you
please flip those late so I can't get
like a role that I want to put the money
into I put late well the one idea it was
like okay this one's pretty good but I
just like my roles have been trashed man
I got one I actually got one legendary
that is 61 oh it is this is probably one
of the first ones I'm gonna take and
also depends on the affinity and because
you never know which one you're gonna
want to use this one has to mobility
strength it's already already not bad
the 19 resilience 10 recovery 21
discipline and 7 intellects oh I saw rip
with no mod
no mod legendary crazy that's crazy but
it's also last season I got the last you
can't even use light but that's another
issue now when we come into all this
damn armour stuff is like if it's this
hard to get it and now I can't get the
damn new perk in there so I'm looking at
a 61 and I'm like I can use them it
could be maybe this is for my like
nightmare hunt grinding I don't know but
I was like dude are you kidding me so I
I'm with you on like you said last time
I'm with you on armor affinity and beat
they just need to be able to change it
if they let you change it I think you're
fine
if they let you give you a material that
allows you to change affinities like
almost like what is it glass needles and
all that stuff from back in the exotics
man that's older deftly on exotics like
that is just that washer your instant
core cost or something like char girls
ain't nobody going to do sir trying to
get that one piece up thing when you
have RNG that could pick any exotic at
any infinity like come on nobody's doing
that but they need to do that but I will
say this way I might disagree with you
though I think I like that certain
armors like last season's had the
nightmare stuff this season there's a
specific set that has the dawn stuff I
like that I have opulent armor that
specifically is full of ayat and stuff
it makes me put on that we didn't we
kind of complain that legendaries there
for different reasons that's what I like
so I'm not gonna lie I do like a yo I
gotta throw this on if I really want
this bonus I should throw these clothes
on I kind of like that man
now what I also let you my new exotic my
severance enclosure the new one for the
season total stat roll guess it mm-hmm
total stats not just anything just total
sixty one five zero
okay
yeah damn my gang aren't Jesus ain't
like you know that's why I'm late no
it's hard to spend like the currency
when I'm looking at this thing I'm like
even if it was like an exotic will you
use a lot if the roles suck and it's the
wrong affinity there's two two reasons I
may not spend currency and it's just
there's a lot of reasons right now so
yeah we got to get you to use your
currency for affinity changes they need
that we need to complain about that then
you'll use their currency that you sit
on all those shards of glass kneel for
like a stat roll on an exotic that'd be
nice if you got an exotic say you get an
exotic and it is the rights that rule
that you want but the stats on it suck
yeah it'd be nice to reroll just like
let me flip a coin and see what happens
make rolls down to if do you like the
one I got maybe it jumps up to 64 and
it's doable so just build a roll you
didn't take it back to d1 on Smith free
roll remember yeah we used to do that
all the time we roll that bad boy and
that'll solve their promises they don't
like us hoarding materials right that'll
solve their problem in a way to cement
some stuff yeah make a spasm stuff we'll
gladly go to the gunsmith and start
gambling we don't sing let's do yeah
gambling it's a problem in this game
yeah we fell off a complete and total
tangent there but Laura yeah so where
were we
long before oh this crazy armor 2.0
hurts is there cool I like the fact that
new ones are in there we got redone
weapons the new weapons are cool the new
linear fusion heavy is so fast mm-hmm
have you used that thing it's like
people you know it's it's so fast
yes sir mm-hmm so your reckoning armor
straight God's here 60 64 plus on every
piece I'm hearing I'm reckoning Thomas
is really good he's fairly I need to go
spend some time and that's depressing go
spend some time in there Tommy I don't
want to go in there
they changed it so it's not as bad but
man then it's been a long time I don't
even I can only imagine the blueberries
that would be running through there
right now yeah it's disgusting I will
say this though I might have to bend the
knee to you on this Eve oh oh I've been
playing a lot of I'm not a game of prime
ever having fun oh yeah but regular
gotta go camber from this way I said oh
I'm having too much fun that all the
builds up it's just so Y prime over
regular this is not let's get to it
so obviously because the pinnacle
situation you know I'm saying you know
that the new you know going up so now I
can do my powerful is again something
alright it's been about a month hiatus
let's get back in the game and get some
stuff for it so I'm just raining in gear
raining and dropped so that's the first
thing that drops the gambit weapons are
amazing most of them you know Sam so the
problem I mean I have a problem but it's
like the one round nature and just the
bosses and stuff III don't know I just
happened and I've been using Lord of
wolves a lot and that thing is just
melting til things and I'm just having
fun
all the way around I'm doing things I
normally wouldn't do because there's no
weapons and a new new stuff that's
happened to Scouts and Lanier's and it's
just fun now like I feel like I have so
many different types of builds for every
place there I'm even invading I never
invade so I'm like yo I'm just I'm
wrecking right now yo it's it's just too
much fun so yeah I've come full circle
you know what's funny Tasi came full
circle to be here with the last two on
the gambit original train and he changed
about a couple months ago yeah but I've
been playing nothing but prime and you
know what it is
the match is in and faster the match has
ended fast you know I'm saying if you
get a good team and and the drain emotes
I can't fight is something to be said
send two big blockers over there and
then invade and you don't even got to do
it you can just sit there chillin whilst
everyone sits right now
like oh come on try and kill these
things oh do we know and it's just like
ding-ding-ding yeah it adds a level of
intensity to that section not saying
when someone invades here like oh god
here they come
but then on top of that you just like
the stress of losing the motes
it's yeah it is a cool aspect of that I
was like I don't know it was just
something yeah hey you know what it is -
now that's helping me is one of the big
problems with prime which what I had was
because there's so many yellow bars
there's so many big beefy bosses that
you would run out he's like damn I got
no heavy in it you know and then you
know there's always that one dude on
your team who's hoarding the heavy spot
like like in Malta and not invading but
all he he soon as he see five seconds on
a power brick in crime he right there
parked over there
so my Tom there's good uses by the way
that's one of them oh yeah as well like
I wish reduce so what I like now is I've
got my heavy ammo finder joint you know
I'm saying then I'm using like my
shotgun ammo scavenger per corner on the
legs so I'm not worrying about having to
be concerned about that one hoarder on
the brick and now I can do damage and
play carefree and I think that was what
my turn off was cuz this there's nothing
more frustrating than Prime when there's
an invader after you and you have
nothing to combat him with just a
primary you know you're finished right
so at least if you have things it makes
it more fun and that's why I think it
changed for me these either the new
armor 2.0 with the mods with those with
those bills and then I've been call it
the Dragon Ball Z build I've been
running with the the Kamehameha
lightening else you knows chaos rage
melting having a ball very a shout out
she had to prom I'm full circle bit I've
been to me I am now full circle crime
lover now and then fact is over here is
like I just love dropping ward of dawn
on the bank and I'm like oh my god oh my
god
just like sit here and be like sup yo
subby here for a good 30 seconds yes yes
me that's file 40 that's oh
feeling bad but as word of dawn if
you're all defense you like just step
into my ring of fire powerful z' aren't
gonna be needed for long mm-hmm but yeah
it'll give you a reason to play for a
minute or two and if you go on for that
shotgun I suppose though Lord of wolves
in there cuz the crucible being the
catalyst is dropping like crazy right
now yeah katal is it dry all you got to
do is that per a medium strike and you
get neither the Black Talon on catalyst
already a lot of wolves catalysts it's
part of your Cyrus quest like what did I
guess I got Lord of wolves I've seen
black town yeah those the two I've seen
a lot of those are cool yeah couple
catalyst surprise catalysts just show up
I love it they don't even tell us
catalysts are there in people but they
drop like it's not like one person's
like I saw and it's like everybody got
the same to some people got both on the
same strike run like they they wait them
real heavy like when the season starts
and I sort by the end of they're like
dropped in percentage until the new
season gets because that's where this
happened last season new season here's
this like influx of like catalysts like
if they trickle them out it almost would
feel better I feel like yeah I feel so I
mean this part there's a part of me that
really likes the secretive nature of how
they did it you know I'm saying put on
yeah we just gotta see more of it if if
this is going to be the cadence let's
just do like let's let's add meta
changes add perks let's add catalyst two
favorite returning things and it just
adds a lot of to me extra play and
longevity to the meta and I'm all about
it so that that's why I'm having so much
fun just go and man decree I'm just
literally thinking about Chris what's
going think zine just ARMA list it's all
you hear it's crazy but it's so I mean
it is weird for them to put a heavy
weapon in crucible because it's so hard
to get heavy ammo so like if you had to
grind out however many kills it is it's
like 125 which actually isn't horrible
mm-hmm it's like 15 s decision kills I'm
like almost done about in like three
games because that's all you're gonna go
for anyway but if you had to wait on
heavy ammo oh my god those heavy bricks
would be just horrible
you'd be
worse than I was with a grenade launcher
mountaintop the stupidest thing I ever
attempted I was in there with my crooked
fen trying to do it and it it's it's
terrible
don't don't do that I I would I'll pull
Arvilla starless gotta come out man yeah
it's got to come out I'm sorry buddy who
doesn't have that or missed it from
something like you're done luckily two
random dropped oh it's a random job -
yeah yeah you don't have that for some
reason you're like how am I supposed to
I feel sorry for the person who will go
through the entire grind working on
heavy to get there and then just finally
pulling their teeth at like their hair
out I'm just like sorry dawn they're so
like there's been quite a bunch like the
story was cool I don't wanna spoil it
but go free go play it that was legit
and this is just part I love outs part
one I was like the guarantees there's
more and it's so good already
mm-hmm so sundial we kind of touched
that but we didn't go too deep on it son
died on the obelisks and the linking and
choosing your rewards and then if you go
up to like level 11 you can have double
rewards like how you feel about all this
stuff so far what are you what are you
digging on first a little confusing I
didn't know how the mechanics work when
I first got to it but um I liked it I
mean like I said there's a level of
grinding for specifically what you want
I felt about the weapon bounties were
fairly fair you don't say they would
anyone have me doing anything too crazy
sometimes it was public events sometimes
was just precision shots what I liked it
it was the one I had to go find 2030
resources alright now what I like I hate
that yeah I want out I even have a combo
detector for every single planet mm-hmm
and it's still annoying yeah you know
it's funny that the planet they have it
I don't have a guys I don't have yeah I
don't have it for that and I was just
like ah did you buy the lunar shell it
was a never verse one if you have the
lunar shell from season 8 you can pull
that one for glimmer and just like
legendary shards over and over and over
and it always comes with a combo
detector and I just pulled them until I
have one or every planet how much is the
cost on a pole you know
it's labeled you know a few thousand
glimmer like seven legendary shards like
it oh I'll do it so Luna show okay oh
yeah yeah just your legendary your
purple charts so it's cheap shot to
which what they say hey did you guys see
the Clovis Bray and if you're referring
to that Twitter ad that Bungie retweeted
that look fire what did you see it what
the yes I know what you're talking about
and it was the it was the weapon frame
yeah the Polaris Lance yeah that's so
that's the people who make the actual
props that they use so it's the company
that's like made the full replicas I
don't know if they were the same company
who did the whisper the full-blown big
giant freakin whisper and they're one of
the ones who I think they make the prop
so that's literally what they do but
yeah that was that was sick that was
really really good the commercial and
the production value like it felt like
Clovis Bray Tech talking like it was
dope yeah like that it was very well
done back to the you know to obelisk
so far so good looks like it didn't you
know quantity season we're gonna be
getting you know some more of those you
know I mean so according to the role map
and stuff like that so I'm definitely
excited I like it I mean you know it's
it's just it's different but I always
like when you can like what Manoj
reintroduced was there Candido having
the level of control over your orangey
and having that level of control now to
grind good weapons so if I want to keep
grinding that what you call it
repeater thing right there the auto to
720 Oertel for better rolls I can do
that you know say that now that new arm
grenade launchers with the wave thermite
thing that I'm going crazy about I can
do that you know um perks a little high
for that new charge like stuff that is
low half of that stuff I agree
you know I'm leveling up the rezident
stuff getting that that rocking but so
far so good as far as now the sundial
itself um what I forgot
what did activities as an E and you care
for it too much but then there's the
other one where um I think you had to
Bank you got almost like everybody has a
little orbs and you got to bring it back
and Bank it and stuff like that and a
boss to spawn again yeah don't kill the
Minotaur it drops you come back
dunk it got to do all three boss funds
rinse and repeat boss spawns again shot
though my name is Bai he was in one of
my random sundown mr. su
like daughter'd I've seen one or two
that I would call like destiny
celebrities and match feels like
everybody stopped Rehana was om oh it
was called sucked ft Sefton one game
before and it was PD nice oh my god we
got destroyed you know with a stack or
not but yeah I gotta destroy if I shot
the bro man they was in they reckon he
was doing his work but um yeah so that
right there and I do like you know the
bosses you know I hope that the
mechanics for each of the bosses is
different I'll be cool I like this one
was a Leviathan of yes Leviathan punchy
mode yes yeah exactly what it was it was
punch really crunch the guy in the
bubble and I was like oh I know this yep
yep but the guy did he had a little
detained yet the busts out the déjame
yeah good adjoint only did is if I'm
using like what was I using I was he
used some fighting line cuz it was like
void cinch in there cuz his void and
grenades no but then I was like and then
I got detained I was like switch weapons
quick no boy or some you know bro you
stop doing that though cuz I was just
running around exploding all the enemies
and all of a sudden I'm detained I'm
like what switch clicking at the wrong
moment it's just straight nerf it you
got that I still like the champions in
it I'm a I think I'm a huge fan of when
they added champions into stuff they
like little mini bosses that you have to
spec out for ya you gotta have that
mechanics covered that like the barrier
is pick where you want to put it it's
Scouts it's it's it's on your rifle so
that one I usually like that one gots
barrier when straight on my go figure
nice and like I told you before I've
been loving leviathans breath because of
that because it has that early on stop
stop oh man it's huge it hits like a
truck so yeah that's what you said the
new symmetry in alternate fire mode is
unstoppable as well I forget where I saw
that yeah when you switch it like the
fire mode you shoot the little
projectiles those apparently will
trigger the unstoppable mmm ice that's a
little functionality god I didn't know
nice yeah I saw one little videos like
oh nice kind of a surprise there
I haven't toyed around without and that
much honestly I need to but that one
looks pretty cool mmm yes shofar I mean
it's it's three-sided so it's not as
deep as binary where you've got like
right six things you might even have a
completely different run like two or
three times in a row
depends on how successful people are but
what the space they have to work with I
think they did a good job because you
have the past's I like the sunbeam
coming down on the dudes head just kind
of fun throw the ball Bheema fire melted
shield feels good
well I was using I think it was just
Grenadier day and I was just chucking
magnetic grenades picking it up throwing
them chuck another magnetic grenade over
here throwing them I was just going to
town on doing that and you can tell the
people that like have paid attention and
played a couple times mmm how fast the
run can go and then when you get
blueberries like hey I logged in for my
first sign of season what am i doing in
here hey yeah those are very different
experiences very much so then if you go
the one you said where you're banking on
the front side from the minotaurs yeah
and you get the boss that comes out that
one's cool it's just the one and I think
I've only seen it once or twice they
struggled at trying to get to like stand
on the plate you have to defend it but
people just suck at that and no one will
stay on it was like going and like I'm
guy I'm trying to put a towering shield
up I'm like I need more walls they need
to build a wall a wall bubble you mean
like word of not honestly there would be
oh yeah that'd be crucial so like those
are the three but also like when you're
like hey which way am I going for the
boss and you're like we're going to the
future this time and I'm gonna be the
other like other directions so mmm yeah
it's so far not bad I like to have got
different bosses
there's some variety at least versus vex
offensive which is just the same thing
over and over yeah definitely I would
definitely so far it's already in my
opinion better
the VEX offense but I need it I need the
mechanics of the other bosses to be
different yes
you can't just put another little sign
on flavor different names yeah
then I will be placed because I don't be
like yeah don't undermine me like the
let's let's give new mechanics for the
bosses you do that I'm good yeah what's
the first one he's void and then I saw
like arc and then what looks to be maybe
so lured by like colors of their close
up thing so if we get three different
ones that way that might be cool yeah if
it's not bubble shields and punched the
little floaty boys in the face if it's
not that even if it's minor but if it is
like if it's something else so maybe
there's a dog over in the corner you
have to kill before he howls and they
just go it's like a mini raid that they
really love I did though that'd be cool
but overall like I'm I'm cool with it
and I think like everything we've just
sat here and talked about so much more
worth than ten dollars or even less if
you got the deluxe like this is not this
is more than I think we expected I think
this is a fair trade for ten dollars
quite easily as you said the one mission
alone that one mission alone blows away
anything in season of the was undying
yeah yes I mean I was paired with shadow
keep if you bought shadow keep you got
it with it so that was never gonna be
huge that was less blacks and people
will worry because they knew that oh no
content that that portion would be
mimicked later and they wanted to know
if they were getting similar value we
don't put future season and one thing
that season of dawn is proving is no no
we're way beefier than that like this
this is not you know that kind of
situation so yeah I agree it's cool to
see let's just see how they go but like
I say honeymoon stage right now dynasty
how this thing plays out so yeah we got
quite a bit of stuff to do and it may
not be the longest season ever but
there's holiday breaks in there we have
one more table and then we're gonna have
a vacation and travel and I'm gonna be
I don't even know I think we might be
able to a podcast next week if it's
stuff to cover we do have the new stuff
launching next week so we probably will
before we go yeah and then iron banner
will be the week of Christmas and the
New Year's so there's gonna be some time
off in there and things got a couple
exotic quests that we haven't even seen
yet this season yeah is there next like
start of the new year in January we've
got the Imperium foundation whole thing
that's going on in there that I'm dying
to know what that is
I am it's is that like the catalyst to
the next season is that the thing that
starts like the trigger of something
when we have that new boss who's in
length and must in time realm are we
like is that we're finally duking out to
figure out where times gonna end up mmm
yeah we got to see I mean have you been
pay attention to the tea leaves with a
certain pinnacle PvP activity uh yeah I
saw that screenshot where did that come
from
where did that come from I don't know
was somebody just like moving their
mouse over and they caught something on
their screen or I don't I don't know
where that came from I haven't looked at
the clip I just saw it running and I was
like bro trials is coming it's just a
bad Oh way back like they literally have
the trials card with not 93 I didn't see
that trials coming at some point I may
not be this season now but it may let
you said lead into you know I'm saying
something for next season where it does
come and I'm curious to see how they do
it storyline wise and I'm curious to see
which way and elimination is now a
permanent part of crucible playlist now
you know nobody out of labs and then a
little it would just like do the
thinking used to and just flip the
trials over the weekend and then flip
back on Tuesday mmm the tea leaves are
there that's all I'm saying
I just need it bad I just did that bad
eat cool gear hopefully its trials of
Osiris you know say he's here so I'll be
dope but um yeah it looks cool it was
really cool to see that on earth to give
me confidence then yeah that was like
this is new said data and everything
else like oh my god something dramatic
was asking about
new dungeons so I don't think I think he
was asking probably about Imperium
foundation I don't get your Imperium
foundation to be like a mercury dungeon
but I was gonna ask you do you think
there's gonna be a hidden like whisper
or outbreak type thing this season as we
don't have a raid we don't have that
type of stuff do you feel he's got a
place for it because there's some gaps
on the Macallan yeah there's a gap
I'm a shout out to the Damned sirens
you're gonna have to deal with it today
you're running loose out here big
covered day they just thank you for your
service all of you all right so now the
service guys a good all right my gut
says no for a weapon only because we got
Devils run on the seventh no of January
then we got Bastion on the 28th that
means right like that's that's a short
distance between the 28th of January and
the February 4th right well yeah it's so
weak it's like one week or whatever so
it feels story II yeah I think the
appearing the foundation is story I was
wondering not like secret non calendar
dungeon like an outbreak that just like
oh oh it just pops up right right right
right well all three weeks of the season
or something like that I don't know man
III think people want those things so I
I just I gotta I gotta pull old-school
like like we just got like Pitta heresy
like it even you know say it didn't even
grown up to a teenager yet like it's
still in the infancy but if you don't
coddle it it baby you don't take your
lawyer has an insulated yet so you
haven't sold I haven't even really
jumped in the outside of what I do I
haven't done it I just jumped in there
would scream to do some things to get oh
yeah you got weird crazy yeah yeah
speaking of things did you find out
what's going on wish Brenda right now oh
yeah I saw it on Paul Tessy yeah you
gotta help me get mine I mean I already
have it I just got to go to the location
under boat remember I didn't pick it up
after we did it together I never claimed
it I never went to that spot whatever it
is I got to do to just actually claim it
because nobody steal yo girl get in
shattered throne again that's where you
have to go get the bow okay yeah the
whole thing again just again three
quarters of the dungeon yeah you get it
you start it there you do the crazy
mission with all the you know three
bosses then you write the three secret
bosses and then the last secret boss is
in the ogre room so when you finish the
ogre you get it when you're done they'll
patch you by the tablet today I would
have played GUI up everybody share right
now hits like four or five robes the
heart isn't supposed to and people are
saying looking is it pvp broken too
I don't know what's going on a pvp but
he is hitting like four to five times
two damage yeah
shout out to TAS he's getting killed
right at it kill it him already bitching
he's like I used to nerf I choose to
nerf this weapon nerd
Leflore but I will agree with him that
the sense that I hope they keep member
we always complained about dungeon
weapons and pain up whoever they need to
have a level of power so maybe they
change it to heaviest stuff do something
where it hits hard yeah somebody's
saying like leave it where it is and
make it a special special no that hits
that hard would be cool cuz like a
little more ammo so like not quite
sniper ammo where you're capped at like
18 maybe it sits in the dirty realm but
it's like yeah let it hit harder because
that thing is a pain in the butt to get
it's none just like your standard
special and they got the numbers nobody
I was like I would love if this was a
secret like buff but I'd be I don't
think it is cuz he was also saying
sometimes it's broken and only hits once
it doesn't even get the double way
through and through the shout-out to a
wishful thing he said did you notice
Imperium foundation match name last
season ever verse matches last season's
ever verse ornaments I did I'm very
furious apart ographers yeah yes yeah I
don't know man I still feel story beat
I feel like story beat we'll find out
maybe something obviously we know
back on st. 14 officially probably on
the 17th you know we got to see what's
gonna happen with fate you know I I feel
story me so that's why I would love it
to be a dungeon I would love it to be a
secret mission weapon you know whispery
kind of thing but my gut says yeah this
is the like season for that kind of
stuff and this probably seemed that the
vibe I'm getting is very you know let's
move the lore along let's you know
figure out what's gonna happen and what
else do we affect by doing these do
things you know with the timelines and
stuff so for those of you guys that are
curious little random thing here but the
word Imperium and shout out to Prescott
I think he said something like this last
time empyrion itself it is an adjective
related to heaven or the sky so then you
go there's a little Wikipedia on the
same thing I looked up it said in
ancient cosmologies the empyrion heaven
or simply the empyrion was the place in
the highest heaven which was supposed to
be occupied by the element of fire the
word derives or the medieval Latin
Empress and adapt an adaptation of the
ancient Greek imperious meaning in or on
the fire hmm but it's synonymous with
season of dawn yeah like you're in the
right place for it cool cuz I don't
sleep I mean empyrion foundation you're
almost like like the birth of time or
like the birth like you're going like
crazy stuff there so it's like
implication wise I think it's story
related with you I'm in the same place
because it's like kind of a calendar
story be it's for everybody which is
weird though because it's everybody on
Mercury unless this is late some people
are wondering when we get done with the
sundial are we gonna like do something
and like fix the mercury put it right so
like a good time or maybe the pastor I
felt like is that the way we're gonna go
back and yeah separate spaces and shock
it back where it's supposed to be yeah
he said the season feels like it's a
setup for something huge in the spring
or summer like this is the calm before
the true storm just a toy it feels so it
feels like you know this is definitely
setting up some other major event and it
looks like to me they look to be
consistent with that so
you know III can't wait man I bet that
date is marked I am very curious about
that whole day when they even said that
like the transition or they didn't say
that word
they didn't say transition but like
going from season of the undying to the
season of dawn is not like how we want
it to go but it's like the beginning so
for all that transition may not have
been as cool we may be leading into a
better building world so they just got a
nailed it man I think like I said if
they do these things with cool story
beats and just transition it properly we
won't have any issues with this level of
content and how it's being presented
indeed what else for season of Don I
feel like we have an entire season and
we manage to talk about this thing in
like an hour and 15 minutes now sirens
again yeah that's fine
plug that gut punch us go push it oh I
mean what else I mean it's still the
season itself is still the activity have
you been have you been touching
pinnacles crazy like where are you at
with that well I gotta get mine 61st yes
I was working on leveling and questing
and I ground-up buzzard and working on
Sun Dial crucible stuff so I haven't
gotten to pinnacle level yet so I'm not
I wasn't 960 so that grant takes a
little while it's not the longest but it
does take a little while I'm starting to
I'm almost 960 on my Titan I need like
two drops mm-hmm so I kind of want to
ask you sir it's Friday
mm-hmm I came out on Tuesday mm-hmm
almost done with my powerful drops there
we go there we go yes like other stuff
too is there enough other stuff to do
now that you focus on pinnacles like
it's like from like 750 to 900 do
everything in the nine yeah so there 950
or now 960 he's still got a good amount
of stuff to do nothing yep little red of
things that you get it's about to be
like if you want a level you don't have
that many options any
I agree and that's why I said honeymoon
phase because once I'm back to that
point again that's where I started to
get frustrated with season of the
undying and I was just like damn like
I'm not gonna be in Gambon anyone less
I'm really going hard for that ritual
weapon you know what I wanted again but
prime is so great now it is great I'm
gonna be in it hello reckoning armor cuz
that stuff so yeah yeah we'll see I mean
that the key is gonna be once we get
there like you just get there now it's
only gonna take us you know that low
like it's a week for a character week
per character it did it's like now what
bureau say and is the artifact enough
right is the content enough you know I
can't tell until that that comes you
know I'm saying until until that coming
it's gonna be for me now
you know since so from next week on I'm
gonna see how my habits change do I peel
back do I fall back is there other stuff
but then I'm not gonna lie the obelisk
stuff it's kind of intriguing to me when
that rebels up when you know what
happens then and you know storyline wise
you know again the part one was
phenomenal we got a part two you know
we're gonna want to do these things so
I'm you know it the key will be do we
not care about the powergrind enough
because we're distracted by the other
things that's gonna be the key because
maybe Bungie is shifting us in this
direction and trying to change our
mindset so they're only the big big
expansions have that power green of how
green power grind that the older you
know what you call it yeah like another
50 or 200 big jump and these are just
like and then take take take
and then BAM that maybe they're
conditioning us to that's how it's gonna
be and you know we got to see we got we
have to see but season adorn is critical
for this I feel like season a Dawn has
to execute this right otherwise people
are gonna be like I went the old way
this is not it you know I'm saying that
the chirps will be there
so it is nice you've got like you've got
different grinds it's not as much like
hair to get my power level well I'm
working on this stuff for the obelisk of
my own crucible matches turning some
this fractal eyes stuff to drop and I'm
get my artifact level up in like the
natural grinding of other things like
reputations you're trying to do in
another game it's kind of like a
reputation almost from like world
warcraft like i need to go do things for
this thing over and over well you're not
getting higher little stuff but like
you're not getting higher level things
but what you do unlock something you
want and it's a different kind which is
something they may actually kind of help
balance that out you having these little
bien PC type things of and this like
these are what people have been asking
for like the planetary vendors mm-hmm
like if Deborah McKay had one of these
things like hey if I'm going there
shooting enemies on the planet and I'm
playing and I can turn in my currency
and I can level him up and I can unlock
some devvra mods and he's got some
specific like hey he sits up in his
little watchtower and sniped everybody
up there and I can get sniper mods or
something and like that's the type of
stuff like say each planetary thing
would be like its own gun a faction
level you loaded them up like this is a
start of us seeing them having the
capability of doing it now they just
implement it but yeah like the obelisks
are a different gun but I think one that
actually has a lot of potential right
and I think if they go that route and
then it becomes to logging in each day
or you know we're leveling up these
other entities or these other factions
for other roles and specific rewards
then that becomes a fun grind and then
we don't necessarily care about the
light light as much because now it's
like yo I got a grind for these things
that are gonna make me more powerful in
conjunction with this season and I think
that's their endgame I'm starting to
figure it I think their end game is to
break our mentality that the power grind
is what it's always supposed to be
that's supposed to be the end-all
end-all look at my number my number is
bigger than your number the i yeah i
think that's overweight yeah exactly
like you don't say so now it's like yo
but your numbers hot
but do you got these do you have this do
you have this weapon you don't say level
20 with ashram near he and I are like
legit like this your voice and you've
got this like awesome thing at 20 you
gotta get it cuz this mod is on fire and
people are like holy crap I going all
you grind up all those crazy factions
hmmm which I don't think they should
reset but I mean they can add stuff as
you go higher right you what are you
adding experience over and over to that
art over and over there yeah and you
still you still getting the beefed up
that you ultimately wouldn't gotta just
turn your fashion we're just getting
into an MMO yeah and here's here's the
thing if they execute it this is where
they win with the problem with destiny
is where they went lay of the year oh
yeah this is where they win over for the
casual the problem with the casual is he
misses two expansions he's too far
behind mmm he's too far behind now every
season they gonna be a new light season
way just you know boom oh so now with
the artifact okay boom then you come
back next season 9 60 or whatever it is
if it's only going up that small
increment that's not too bad that's not
too bad for a new person to
quote-unquote have to catch up so to
speak like because you're doing the
a-la-carte thing if you get where I'm
going
yeah and I'm saying so they can jump in
they could be like yo I don't have to do
seasonal down I'll jump in season to the
door now and I can be right there it's
not like they're up 200 light levels
ahead of me all my hardcore friends like
it's discouraging it's discouraging so
they they're on the right track I'm
learning what they're trying to do I
think it is cool you know if we do it
this way but they've got to execute
content and they've got to execute cue
the grind for these other things that we
leveling up like the obelisks and
whatever Imperium is gonna be what
happened was really cool then I think we
can kind of get on a lot get in line
with this system yeah and by the way
shut up in the end of the season pass
that part get 92 what is
Sundaya lipids can drop with an
alternate final perk so your new weapons
now have two picks at the end if I'm
reading there right you want to tell me
how important that's gonna be when you
get later on billing oh I got my season
well now I can grind out these things
like I can have like alternates on the
end mm-hmm to the perks that's given
exotic cat I mean what is a catalyst
progression on some of those things I
all I think about is the Arianna's join
member I like slow the percentages was
all and yeah like if they got something
to boost it I like stuff it will be in
there again it's there in a coal crisis
yeah good good oh yeah if I mean if I
got my steel feather repeater with like
elemental capacitor and multi kill clip
I can just choose like or mix it up like
if that's what we're gonna have it the
mind that gives you a different reason
to go back be like chunk these ones out
there let me get these with like
alternate and you get that chance of
that even better role so when you get to
the end of the season more if you
haven't got it yet
now get your money in there cuz now you
can do it twice got one beef though oh
not that use that it's not but with this
season with the season arm passing the
way they explained it was that at the
end of the season if you were behind
right you could pay to catch up have you
tested that that a strategy sir what was
it how much per level like a hundred
silver oh yeah it's always level it's a
dollar a level so let's just say brah
it's a hundred so let's just say you
didn't play and now you cover that the
way made it seem it'll be like a $10
price or a final price or whatever the
price was and then you get all this
stuff so like our shooter um who's the
shop data here I've missed a couple of
weeks for whatever reason no so he's
like yo I gotta get that dad dad dad
armor that you know the Titan wings and
you know saying effects see like armies
like yo I've missed out just I gotta get
to whatever and we were looking at the
joint and it was like $1 per level
Bunji Bunji come on that's a little
crazy how's it look I've really talked
about that
I think I don't I can't remember where I
even saw that cuz like I was a hundred
before it mattered and then I saw
somewhere else and I was like seriously
mm-hmm I was I was very perplexed at the
price let's just say that because it was
it was a bit steep yes yes I think like
hey $10 for the whole damn thing if you
want to finish it out and then prorate
it for the levels that you haven't got
there and like get reasonable for so
somebody's like hey I got like 50
somebody spent like a dollar 50 to
finish up their season pass but they're
not gonna spend like what would the $15
$15 $15 just to get 15 levels it's like
no no no cuz then I think and that's the
point of like where they I still I don't
know who's I guess bouncing the silver
cost of things cuz they were a silver
economy still is very very skewed it's
very young right dust is I mean yeah I'd
like to earn more but the price of
things for silver and maybe there are
whales that always settle these
statistics off and that's why
everybody's always pissed off but if
things were cheaper I would buy more of
them because I think I'd get more out of
my value I would spend $30 for more
things and then I'm like oh I want to
get this like if I get one set and it's
like ten dollars for one I'm only
probably can do this like one time like
that's my mentality and I'm probably not
everybody but if I could get like six
pieces or slike seven ornaments for like
you know 25 buy like get more for my
money I would spend more I know that
sounds stupid but I probably would know
it's real it's really sad to see free
say yeah say it's deep they probably got
a metric ton of people shopping over $50
to finish stuff out and then shout out
to Blackwood he's mentioned in Esther
Allegan he said three weeks of
restaurant with dawning racing and
getting unique spirals and gears would
really have helped with the slow point
in the season but what you're gonna do
I agree I think these were the these
type of seasons where you know you're
not gonna have you know dungeons and
raids I think you need to have stuff
like srl you know I'm saying in faction
rally and you know I'm saying that's
when you kind of bring that stuff in to
kind of ease the pain of not the the
bigger you know pinnacle activities so
I'm an agreement well speaking of
donning we do have that Cup everybody
ready to be icicle covered you can get
your
horn golden-crested great looking armors
crazy isn't it hold the crop is crazy
yeah almost crazy
I liked last year's a little better but
this is a little weird we want a weird
side yeah they are ridiculous also if
you did not get an avalanche last season
or not a great role you can go for it
this season my cross like I get crap on
armor I haven't infused that much stuff
but my feeding frenzy I may have got two
of them last season earned my Avalanche
and I got like the God role what you got
would you guess I'm looking for it
feeding frenzy and rampage on it I'm
pretty feeding frenzy a rampage ricochet
rounds and like a medium scope now
question is data ornament that I see for
black tile and looking frosty like is
that yes looks like yeah I saw that one
I had to get that I go he said that
Titan armor looks makes you look like a
gilded gingerbread cookie hunters like
hunter is probably the most low-key
actually Titan is like Titan is like a
mountain goat yeah yeah she's like a
when you said gilded I was like yes and
then you said gingerbread cookie I was
like no no it's a mountain goat with
like the curled horror Ram yeah like
curled girl joints yes and then yours is
like almost like a antelope or whatever
yeah like the big get a big like a year
a little gazelle kind of thing I like to
help me I don't know how I feel about
this list dis a chafing going on at the
bottom I don't know how I feel about
that thing yeah it's like come on you
won't go with the dress do it all the
way like those are always wearing
dresses every soft and you got to put on
a skirt okay
throw this look oh no I just need to
turn the skirt sideways sideways but I
mean they're covered and it's fine yeah
yes but I do like the arms I do it I
love to shout out to polar bear on
Twitter they made Romero for her dude
yeah it's actually on zcp last night I
don't know
to that a solution she's really cool I
met her at DCP she's nice but yeah the
polar bear sparrow
Mike this is like ridiculously awesome
dude some of the sparrows they've done
they've got the toaster sparrow out
there did you see the lord of wolf
Sparrow last season yes
fire fire lazy that yeah and then the
slow ghost what I would hope for is for
people like me with the Cross save
account so you made the tough decisions
right I hope that they bring back the
opportunity with engrams to get some of
the older dawning armor cuz I missed out
on some and I love the dawning sets like
those are some of my favorite man so if
I could get some of them helmets in them
they need like a you know what is it
called like a classic remembrance Engram
oh yeah you know I'm saying yeah I will
love that back cuz I'm a fan of doing it
man cuz you know the snow balls go come
back no fun stuff
do you like the finisher the ice-skating
slice a head off
yeah yes I like that when are you gonna
cut dammit
there we go we even talked about that
SMG I know the cold front basically it's
an entire piece but it looks like an
entire piece in dawning color schemes
mm-hmm Oh shot the black weekend hunters
get a good-looking helmet like the Titan
to the Bulldogs come on man I want to
look like a badass RAM with snowy wizard
hunt you don't have that a freakin hood
all the time look you want to be ninjas
man you gotta have you got the cloak you
normally have the coolest looking class
item
ya know I know buddy has ever been able
to compare to the hunter sion cloaks
ever oh yo those got to come back to
cease we've agreed right flavor lien
we're already killing one of the flares
and we even seen him yet so I doubt it
gotta had that back that's what a the
gold cloaks
for the huntin yeah so we'll be baking
cookies again it seems like so cookies
delivered and confections made so we'll
be working the SMG and the avalanche
from last year it's another solar
machine gun it's a cool one yeah my
feeding frenzy rampage roll
just been locked into my vault forever
nice um to see if there's anything else
on the table so yeah next week we've got
the necess and EDC obelisks we've got aa
slick the sky pure search so he's a new
one and then the save a legend I don't
know if this is part two of more or just
like part 2 of 2 I think part 2 of 2
that's the vibe I'm getting
and I think now we bring them back and I
don't think he's staying home I don't
think so either
yeah I don't think he's staying around I
think I think we're gonna interact with
him a different time which is cool but I
don't think he I don't think he can stay
like I did yes he's been dead too long I
think that'd be weird it's gonna be
interesting how they resolve but I'm
gonna agree with you I don't think he's
gonna be a permanent fixture and if he
went to the tower he just kicked this
avala right ha ha yeah it makes a power
struggle you don't say this is the
greatest time that like he was the
vanguard
commander like so at the end of the day
you know I can't see it and the issue
with the tower right now is not Titans
Titan abundance we have money now
neither we need a hunt item is we need a
hunter we need a hunter in there so you
know the question is how is it resolved
does he go back in the infinite forest
does he that I had a little barrier you
know a little baby he stays in mercury
with Osiris didn't he run those routes
I mean it was it was described as like
you know your fight that you dude now is
the reason we are where we are right
there's that discussion that said and
it's like he's I don't know maybe
yesterday's that come to peace or accept
that or something but it's like we are
where we are because of what he was what
he did right so it may be almost just
like experiencing his journey with him
and then the end it's just like coming
to peace with the fact that we need
certain events to take place for us to
be where we are right maybe I don't know
I'm throwing I mean every but we'll say
no no you saying some stuff that has
some weight I mean one thing about his
personality without spoiling too much is
he his personality is one of ultimate
sacrifice I feel
that to me is who he is he's going to
put you know him himself put others
ahead of himself I'm saying that's the
vibe I get from him so you know the
question though again once it's resolved
you know he may make a self decision you
know Sam and we got to see he you know
he may not be like this is you know this
my fate was was my fate does they cut it
this we got to see hey my question to
you is this we all know trials at some
point is coming back right sad no my
question to you is how do you think
story-wise
they bring trials back lore why like
what do you what do you think would be
the new reason to do this before it was
all the first trial size was okay
Osiris this mystical figure we don't
know at that time indeed when we never
seen it's preparing that's for something
great it's greater than crucibles it's
bigger than anything shacks is doing
this is the true test right then we had
crazy psychic emissary of the nine she
comes in the nines giving you gifts or
prove yourself judgment you know
whatever whatever did famously a big fan
there Wow
clearly I'm biased here you know what I
dislike just like get mad way like crazy
okay what crazy voodoo faces win it and
going up go see her big face that's what
I would see black wings know what type
of time I'm going so my questions like
you're doing is the idea so just throw
it out there lots baby is like what if
as much as I want oh sorry mate what if
they used a carrot he's the greatest
Titan right yeah what if it's like trial
at a saint or something like where he
trains us you know for whatever you know
the next big game of the season Savior I
was close Savior yes yeah that's another
thing that's the title you know I'm very
curious lore wise what with the training
and fight before and who runs it learn
if it's Charles of Osiris I think he's
got to be there
right I think by name that's what
everybody wants as he's in the season if
he sticks around if he sticks around the
one that is weird if he sticks around
cuz the sundial is gonna go away risin
baby grill won't stay oh don't look like
the type and dude then be sticking
around oh can I get something out the
way I forgot about this sagar
Osiris is the most disrespectful
Guardian let me tell you why this man
has returned
he has his biggest fan boy chilling in
so have y'all go into mercury have y'all
go into the right house brother Vance
does not know Osiris is here he did not
get the memo there is no new dialog
there was the poor fanboy Vance his idol
is literally Donovan didn't have the
decency to let him know that he has
returned and poor vase sitting it a
clown of a beer no notification don't
please whatever you guys do go to the
lighthouse and talk to this this bed
that has no idea no I'm like come on man
I felt bad for Vince I'm like damn
that's foul they got to do something for
Vance made like I'm wondering if Osiris
stays around if he has any interaction
with trials coming next season if he's
gonna not be temporary the sundial is
gonna go away well permanent like
mercury change or fix and then he is
gonna be the one hanging out on mercury
still like access the names and Horus so
we can still check timelines do what he
does with the vex when he's chilling out
there maybe either with Vance or
something like that or both and Vance is
there and he's your trials fender maybe
something because they'd be a god
disappearo Levin goes if it's on the
same track both of his places the
sundial just deuces cuz they're not
gonna leave the sundial get rid of an
activity but go interacted with them in
the sundial that's just like I agree
chill I agree
I really I agree yeah it's it's it's
interesting I'm very I'm very curious
and then obviously we have the say 14 as
an option you don't think Eastham you
could be right I think I'm leaning your
direction no I think we get to go on a
journey with him and experience the
character which is cool because people
have always wanted hey I'd love to go
back and see the Battle of six fronts or
whatever like I'd love to go see those
this is a tease of a way for us to go
experience stories ah that's my guess I
could be completely full of it never
don't yeah but yeah we have the dawning
we have the necessaries and necess and
EDC obelisk we have the new boss we have
save a legend all of that starts on
Tuesday yeah
after that we've got iron banner and
another boss and then that's literally
it until we get to the holidays I know
I'm gonna be doing some traveling during
the holidays I know you might as well if
we're both sitting at home we'll do a
podcast will tell you guys that probably
next week sounds like we're gonna have
enough to cover and then I think I'll
still be in town I don't think I'm gonna
drive down that soon mmm-hmm but then
after that we might be off for Christmas
week I think so I probably won't be
available for that one gotta get black
wings on this one he's hitting
heartstrings he said maybe that's the
payoff at the end of the season Osiris
talks to brother Vance
it tells him to start the trials again
yo that would be for me that that would
be the perfect story beak for me then
you vindicate Rance
you have him you have what you call
advanced in the towel all the time I
mean the mercury all the time Osiris may
come as Jets for the weekend right and
then he goes doesn't infinite for us
then and we go hey you know I'm saying
cuz let's be real story as much as our
loved Osiris the character when you look
at it says the exiled warlock he's not a
dude that she's gonna be standing around
talking about he's not our right so it
makes sense it makes it and then I I did
I go with your theory I think saint-14
is a temporary thing you know saying I
think I don't necessarily think he's
gonna be a permanent NPC from now on in
the all-day everyday so we shall see
anything else you want to cover this
week I know we're getting closer towards
two hours I mean we got the dawn
incoming we have a cookies but that big
thing is nothing lasts a month guys
don't rush it there's gonna be a cool
cosmetic sparrow and a ship and things
that you can earn but you have a month a
whole damn month
don't don't break your face over trying
to do it in the first few days of course
content creators we're gonna try and
figure out all the optimizations and
strategies and such but generally
seasoned add-on nothing too crazy for me
on that one yeah yeah somehow a season
comes out we did three hours last week
season wasn't even this week hour and 47
minutes whole new season to talk about
we blow through it so do you want to see
if you have questions or anything
because I know next week we're gonna
have a couple other things to talk about
but if you have questions I think feel
free to comment on the videos on either
place that you see this on YouTube both
the iron Lords podcast channel my
youtube channel either of our Twitter
accounts comment somewhere if you guys
want to get in our discord I get you
guys of my discord it's kind of where we
have our last one chats in there as well
so if you have any interest in those
we'd love to do some you know Q&A with
you guys if you like and we kind of do
some of them live or if you guys anyway
as we read chat but mm-hm just generally
like stuff between the weeks if you
think of something let us know but I
think that's all I got to I mean I know
we're gonna jump in in we're three days
into the season there's not this big
like raid hanging over our head or a
dungeon right coming it is somewhat
smaller stuff so yeah so far I will
definitely say though happily worth what
I paid for
happily worth the value so far you know
I'm saying again if they keep with like
I said the level that we got with the
part one of the same foreign team stuff
you know the obelisk stuff it's cool you
continue that the bosses in its sundials
long as they have some changing
mechanics this would be way you know
worth the $10 we still have the mystery
mysterious empyrion fact you know
foundation that we all curious about we
got some exotic quests you're gonna mean
look price of admission is more more
than worth it so I'm in pocket
you know there's got a
you know state state of course you know
it's a hold on ancient the frost over
there just ready was good and release
he's not brother Vance he's not gonna
stand in the road doing nothing for you
listen
Osiris disrespectful he didn't even talk
to Vance he'd even let Vince know heat
was back how disrespectful is there so
we got to see what happens hopefully
Vance deserves a better afraid oh oh you
shot the front off Ross he said the
appearing is the name of an exotic helm
he got a great article or some game in
that net y'all please check him out but
um yeah that's why I got me but we shall
see but so far so good
based on the value and the content I
can't wait to see how the story beats
progress well yeah that's pretty much we
can wrap it up are you guys gonna be
talking about the new ITX Microsoft
thing on Sunday the my Theresa Microsoft
ITX PC yes the tower the phone an ITX is
like the smallest motherboard size micro
ATX it really looks like a my tray it
migrates straight out today this job for
the baby server you're gonna have the
baby baby computer it's all it is yes
that's where we going man yeah we
definitely could be talking about that
we may have have a special guest you
know I'm saying so we gonna definitely
talk about that we're gonna talk about
hell-blade two we're gonna talk about
the awards everything that went down lot
of topics so we have especially as we
shall see we are working out the
particulars with that but of course a
little podcast 11:00 a.m. Sunday on the
on log podcast YouTube channel and also
Lourdes a gaming dotnet you see ancient
of frost in here he is our editor in
chief at log net please support these
guys they've been doing tremendous all
during the game Awards they're breaking
the stories they're breaking coasters to
see me looking amazing cherry blossoms
and everything all the cool games all
the hottest news get your behind over
the Lords of game that net share those
articles retweet those articles if you
see something that you like because we
really appreciate you the xbox
refrigerated Xbox series extra density
three yeah man see buddy wanna dance
yeah man so check us out man of course
and then king of the statues that'll be
up around 12 what King David always
showcasing new things and of course
every Friday the
know what Cognito a bot is breaking down
that can't fire a destiny talk the way
you want it so that's all I got man well
for me um I'm gonna be playing working
streaming just all my usual stuff and I
finished up as I said the Saint mission
part 1 which was cool Oh fire it was
cool I really enjoyed that one though
yeah more plane and grind ado be working
on some of the ritual weapons of course
but in some timing game it got some
things to shoot with a shotgun of course
yeah be proud whoa it's the only thing
and somebody said it earlier in chat if
you are we're gonna ritual weapons
regular just has more things to shoot
daddy's true that's about the only issue
everybody I got two rounds but other
than that and definitely prime will be
fun I need to just chest out reckoning
to see what these armor drops are like a
Forte got me - I would check that out
myself so that's about all I got you
guys can find me on Twitch twitter
youtube everywhere
follow like subscribe working on that
50k number you guys are awesome thank
you for the support we all grown out
here so keep being awesome it is pretty
much where we're gonna wrap it up so for
December 13th this has been episode
number 84 with the co-host of greatness
over there
mr. Lord Cognito and myself II pontus
and to wrap this thing up it has been
the last word